[Music]
this year's ncaa tournament has already
delivered so many of the memorable
moments it's become known for but with a
twist athletes have been able to
capitalize on their instant fame doug
eddard from the cinderellas at st peters
university signed a deal with buffalo
wild wings while a cheerleader for
indiana was able to turn this viral
moment into a marketing campaign
brook silva braga is here with the story
of how new rules are changing college
sports brooke good morning good morning
guys well since last july college
athletes have been able to profit from
their name image and likeness nil for
short making money from jersey sales and
endorsement deals is a way for players
to share in the massively lucrative
world of college athletics but these new
rights have also created legal ways for
boosters to pay athletes and that's
brought some new and unlikely people
into the center of college sports
miami lawyer john ruiz has made a
fortune litigating against insurance
companies if a planned acquisition of
his business goes through this summer
he'll be worth more than 20 billion
dollars does it have a bad law but john
ruiz and his money are relevant to this
story only because he's also a big fan
of university of miami athletics
gokaines and has started paying miami
athletes as product endorsers for his
new health app
life wallet i love life wallet i love
life wallet what's the budget so we set
out 10 million dollars for the calendar
year 2022. for nil dudes
yes and how much of that have you been
able to spend we've put out almost two
million already the money is going to
dozens of miami athletes from six
thousand dollars a year for volleyball
player angela grieve i assume this isn't
what you expected when you became a
college athlete no definitely not up to
60 000 for star quarterback tyler van
dyke ruiz emphasizes it's not a handout
athletes required to make promotional
videos and take training to improve
their communication skills but the fact
the money might also attract new talent
to miami is lost on no one when you
invest 10 million dollars i assume you
hope it'll have an impact on the field
there's no doubt do i want the
university of miami to win absolutely
the idea all of this is allowed now is a
giant change for college sports and it
follows decades of the ncaa forbidding
athletes from being paid even when fans
bought their jersey even as college
sports became a 14 billion dollar
industry people were really sympathetic
to the athlete and the ncaa became the
enemy
sports business reporter darren revell
covered decades of promised but mostly
stalled ncaa reform then last summer
reform was imposed on college sports
when several state legislatures passed
laws giving their athletes name image
and likeness rights just as the supreme
court dealt another blow to ncaa control
ruling they'd violated anti-trust law
the ncaa once they lost that case went
all right you guys figure it out college
athletes can be in commercials now dr
pepper it's the one dj deserves in a
flash college athletes one new freedom
life is a lot like a race university of
central florida track star renaia jones
started doing commercials for a local
bank
that pays 1500 a month has it changed
your life as a college athlete it
actually has you know it just really
puts me in a better position for my
finances especially when i graduate says
my name on it you know running back
isaiah bowser sells t-shirts it's like
your own website that's right
shopbowser.com
but pretty much immediately college
boosters also started making websites to
gather money into nil collectives louis
padilla is ceo of dreamfield the company
that helped university of central
florida fans launch their collective
called mission control what's a
collective a collective is really a
group of alumni boosters that come
together and pull resources and then
they can just hand out the money in
envelopes or what uh no not necessarily
there are rules around it to stay clear
of ncaa eligibility rules the money
can't be an inducement to recruit a
player to a specific school it can't be
tied to their play on the field and the
athlete must do something in exchange
for the money that justifies the amount
they're paid they gave me like a
contract and i got like deliverables
that i got to do each time mission
control had wide receiver ryan o'keefe
make a social media post go tell
somebody your mama your auntie anybody
that's got a phone to go and sign up for
mission control there's the deliverable
that i just completed that has to be the
easiest 350 bucks you ever made that's
what i'm saying but the nil dollar
amounts are growing dramatically higher
at the upper echelons of college
football there's schools that have no
shot to recruit certain high school
players because they're going to go to
where they're paid the most leading some
including ole miss football coach lean
kiffin to insist the deals are being
used to win players oh brooke you've
come to the right guy because i'm going
to tell you about the ugly side of nil
lawyer mike caspino negotiates on behalf
of high school players and says some
collectives are aggressively skirting
the rules by offering this
we will pay you a large sum of money
just south of a million dollars but we
could ask you to pay it back plus
interest
at any time we like they're doing that
so that if a student doesn't go to their
school they can ask for the money back
correct
i have no problem with players getting
paid in a free market scenario if you
want that but do not masquerade it as
name image and likeness
it's not
john ruiz the one booster willing to
speak to us on camera says he's
following the rules and not using nil to
recruit normally if you look at the nil
deals that we have we give them to the
kids after they committed
not before
and he says all those life wallet videos
prove his athletes are doing real work
make sure you hit the app so you don't
strike out in exchange for the millions
he's paying go to your app store and
search for this blue icon but it's worth
noting after nearly three months of nil
promotion the life wallet app has just
one written review in the apple app
store and fewer than 100 downloads from
the google play store
still ruiz says he's gotten his money's
worth through publicity from news
stories like this one i mean anybody can
say whatever they want but you know take
them to a court of law and have them say
that we're not getting our bang for the
buck but who would do that in many
states local agencies or the
universities themselves are left to
police the hazy field
of name image and likeness
if the ncaa is hands off this will
become the new free market system what
are you worth whatever a booster is
willing to pay to get you to this school
the ncaa declined to comment for our
story but it said previously they're not
investigating nil violations but will
enforce other college rules that
prohibit paying recruits or paying for
on-field performance the ncaa has also
called on congress to clear up this
patchwork of state laws and pass a
national nil law but that is not
expected anytime soon
it is complicated it's also tougher for
college students because it takes years
to build up your name and likeness right
which is why many pro athletes get paid
so much but they're only in college for
a few years four years yeah yep or even
less and what we're seeing is it's what
you say jeff athletes that have built up
their brand maybe they're not the
biggest stars on the field but if you
have four million instagram followers
you can monetize now here's a clue to
why he's not so concerned about the
payback he's a billionaire so i mean
wouldn't you think that that a booster
that had that kind of you know
uh background and and largesse
why would it matter to him what comes it
back on the other side and he's
certainly not the only one who perhaps
cares more about what's happening on the
field than on the balance sheet and he's
he's straightforward about it so he says
yeah i want my team to win
all right brooke thank you very much